warm und stickig
das hat sich echt nicht gesund an
die habe ich vergessen absolut unsere
geschickt
es wird genauso zurückgeschickt
ich mach dir ein bild karten kartentrick
mal ich zeige ich jetzt kein break
[Applaus]
ein dass sie habe ich ja noch nie
verstanden 899 auch mal
was machen 100-jährige die dürfe
[Musik]
also ja es ist cool dass hier stoppt
mobbing auf dem spiel drauf steht und
ich glaube jeder ist gegen mobbing aber
keiner
sonst keine personen die wirklich immer
mobbt fertigmacht beleidigt wird sich
doch dann denken medien beleidige ich
jetzt nicht weil auf diesem spielstand
drauf stopp mobbing das ist genauso wie
diese bilder an so autobahn lokstedt
handy weg das hängt er noch genau an
diese stelle dabei ich habe euch
übrigens gar nicht gesagt wo ich bin ist
aber glaube ich irgendwie auch logisch
ich glaube ich habe in köln auch schon
das aufgenommen
preis für die dümmste steckdose der welt
geht auf jeden fall an dich
das messer hier oben sind einfach auf
diesen monster.com lecker und schreib
mal bitte und in die kommentare die
wassermelonen waffen nein die leute so
dass das sagen
haben und zu kommen fliegen
[Musik]
auf jeder einzelnen karte steht stoppen
morgigen tauchen friedens ernährung in
einer schublade schokolade und salat und
hauptsache das einen teller noch
komplett voll aber schon ein sehr und
noch mehr honig das sieht auch schon wo
nicht
[Musik]
draußen
wir wollten die basketball spielen gehen
wird nur leider nix wir haben neue
spieler entdeckten davon gerade sechs
runden gespielt ich habe einfach alle
gewonnen hätte es einfach schlecht zu
verlieren denn nicht so gut war meinte
peyton dass ich als belohnung mc donald
s
[Musik]
ich hätte gerne zwei macs
hätten ist die einzige person die sich
in welchen bürger ohne bacon bestellt
kennt ihr das wenn ihr so im
formuliere ich das jetzt simpel und
prägnant kurz für einen clip ente dass
wenn ihr euch im spiegel an punkte
denkbar
wenn ihr den spiegel guckt und wenn ein
foto macht dann war ich will einfach
sagen dass gegen wie sie bei dem spiegel
immer deutlich besser aus als man noch
vor das aussieht
20.15 ist einfach so eine zeit die
deutschland repräsentiert ist wenn so 15
jetzt geht auf jedem sender irgendein
film los
disco pogo und ihr eure wassermelone
auch immer eine polonaise bevor die
erste tages war jetzt vorbei da wäre
allerdings nicht so richtig erlebt haben
glock ich morgen auch noch
die 40 stunden er aber dass jetzt auch
immer diesen moment wenn das hoch des
machbaren screenshot von mir und
schickte mir auf install dann hab ich
vielleicht beim ein neues cooles bild
was sich hochladen kann
das übrigens die schlechteste
autofahrerin europas die nachhallzeit
langhans delaware aber es ist wirklich
leider payton
herzlich und billig qualität hat
übrigens von einer grundschule in einen
basketballverein gespielte meinte sie
wird jedes mal den kopf treffen
[Musik]
ist einfach new york auf wunsch bestellt
der größe und den ich hier gesehen habe
dass aber ein alter opa das schiff
bringen
das essen etwa termine
ich war eigentlich das sagt eigentlich
nur unternehmen
ja keine ahnung wo das hochwasser zeigen
die völker auf das gar keinen sinn
ergeben hat dass sich jetzt gesagt habe
dass ich den heutigen tag auch noch
locker weil ich einfach überhaupt nichts
das boot ich finde das hier so gelaufen
ist das so vielleicht den nutzern
mittlerweile in köln angekommen mache
jetzt einen kleinen trödelmarkt weil ich
halt bald aus meiner wohnung hier
erstmal ausziehe für drei monate weil
dann alles umgebaut wird und deswegen
kommen gleich ein paar freunde vorbei
die ihnen nicht ein paar sachen schenken
will
das müssen aber lange kommt so
zusammen wir hier
[Musik]
die leitung kommt verschmutzung nevadas
wasserverschwendung aber es muss sein
kann
ich arbeite diplomat wollte
die sache ist dass ich an meine ganze
wohnung alles genau sortiere ich habe
gesagt verschenkt hatte meine freunde
und die direktive wunderschönen bilder
in sicherheit sind von pablo picasso
damals jahr vorlauf jetzt aber sieht man
auch wenn sich das unding ist die würde
ich mit einer gruppe aufrecht mich als
ich mein staubsauger zwei lampen pushen
und zwei kissen
danke da wird sich neben den drei
packung kaugummis verkauften schuhe und
sie da nicht rein in die schule kommst
du da nicht rein sowie typen die
schwanger werden wollen
auf erst er würde
die schwarzen haben
190 euro gekostet ich hatte die kein
einziges mal an du scheiße jetzt nicht
aus wenn nicht wegschmeißen erklären das
ist nicht annähernd so lange
es ist der raum ist die größte nicht
was zu den schulen doch richtig passen
würde
kommt schon sehr gefährdet kennt ihr
euch mal alle im kreis drehen
das macht
ich wollte einfach nur eine runde
flaschendrehen spielen
wir von dir kommen können
luca ich habe eine frage
kannst du mir sagen wer das ist
okay und wer jetzt sein dass
wir den grünen
wähler unreif
haben jetzt auch jedem neuen katar
servus ich mach das richtig gut kannst
wieder einstellt kann
ich sagen dass wir sie wieder gehen
explodiert die einfach und dann sitzt
luka wieder da la hau kreis
der stelle durch den heutigen tag ist
allerdings auch wenn meine lieben
freunde schreiben meine kommentare wir
eine neue kamera findet zu beginn des
blogs habe er gesehen dass bei einer
alten kamera die zum kaputt gegangen ist
soll ich meine neue kamera abgeholt ist
[Musik]